This is the third time we've taught the
Archeology of harvard yard
and this has been by far and away the most
rewarding experience because we found what we were
hoping we might find.  The last thing we just did was eighty- four
This is a very large stone, larger than the others that we found
we think it was a dried laid foundation of some sort and they took out most of the materials to use somewhere else
but this is one of the larger pieces that
they left behind what we are thinking is it is a robbed wall
trench
a trends that was filled with building materials
where a Wall had originally stood seventeenth
century
building materials in the trench so we believe
it actually might be
original wall location for the Indian college
we weren't sure if we be able to find anything
directly related to the seventeenth century
harvard Indian college
we knew about where it should be
proximate size of the building we knew that
it had been demolished that it had been actually
taken apart in sixteen ninety five
so they weren't sure if there's going to be
anything at all left
we've already found a great deal of uh print
type. We know that the first printing press was in
the Indian college and
we've got a lot of really good seventeenth century
pottery markers and pieces of pipe stand that are
definitely seventeenth century
so we have material that is definitely associated
with the Indian college and now we think we've
got the edge of it so it's very exciting and
yeah know how we're going to live with ourselves
for two years knowing its there
we're just going to have to be patient
it's going to build up a lot of excitement
for the next time we
have class